this is penny mordant's moment from the
sidelines to the center of british
politics the junior trade minister
currently second in the conservative
leadership race topping polls of party
members a surprise front-runner to be
the next prime minister this referendum
is about you
the british people
taking back control
her vote leave credentials winning
support from brexiteers her military
background also giving her an advantage
but her supporters say it's her personal
qualities and struggles that have
propelled her to the top
she grew up in hampshire
her mom died when she was 15 years old
and penny took over the role of bringing
up her younger brother supporting
herself through college
and everything everything that penny's
achieved she's done it through her own
hard work
showing early on a desire to make an
impact as an mp she appeared on
celebrity diving show splash
briefly the first female defense
secretary she was sacked by boris
johnson revenge for backing his rival
jeremy hunt in the 2019 conservative
leadership race
and the prime minister not her only
critic lord frost her former boss
through brexit negotiations said she was
so incompetent he had her moved to
another department a view seized on by
rival camps in the race and i think we
have to listen to
what he's saying because in the end this
is about choosing not just next lead to
the conservative party but the next
prime minister and it is telling i think
where current members of the government
are placing their support and uh i think
you know that is
reflected in davis comments but also
reflected in a number of very senior
ministers decisions about who to support
in this race they are not backing this
morning she's also been criticized by
opponents for being too woke on trans
rights accused of not defending
biological women in legislation when she
was equality's minister
away from westminster in penny mordant's
hometown of portsmouth where she was
inspired to serve in the navy and is now
the area's mp what do people hear make
of her rise
she's young ambitious
um she says it as it is basically i
think it's a positive people want a
clean break maybe we do need someone
who's completely new and fresh face
a political journey from the coast to
the corridors of power taking out more
established rivals can she fight her way
to the top
liz bates sky news westminster